after years of hiding unit sales data
for the Xbox One in 2022 Microsoft
finally decided to release official
sales numbers for the console and they
were rather disappointing throughout the
Xbox One's lifetime Microsoft was only
able to sell a total of 58 million
consoles which in isolation is a great
number but in comparison to the
competition and the Xbox's owned
predecessors the number is rather
underwhelming for perspective the PS4
which had an identical lifespan was able
to sell exactly double units at 117
million even the PS5 which released just
3 years ago is at 46.6 million units and
is on track to overtake the Xbox One in
terms of sales the Xbox series x/s was
supposed to be the console that finally
turned around this trend from Microsoft
but it seems like the disparity is only
getting worse in fact looking at Global
monthly sales it appears that the Xbox
is already starting to lose Steam while
the PS5 is actually gaining steam now
it's true that Nintendo has had consoles
that have flopped way harder like the
Wii U which barely sold at 13 million
units but there's a major difference
between a Nintendo console flopping and
a Microsoft console flopping you see 57%
of Nintendo's total earnings come from
Hardware Sales meaning that they are
very much capable of selling a niche
console and still coming out on top
financially the same however cannot be
said about Microsoft who sells the Xbox
for a loss and this isn't spe ulation
either Microsoft's gaming CEO Phil
Spencer has admitted that every single
Xbox series x/s console is sold for a
loss of up to
$200 since then Microsoft has hiked the
price of the series X in certain regions
by less than $100 but even assuming that
Microsoft only loses $100 per console on
average the Xbox series X and S have
already lost the company over2 billion
dollar and it hasn't gained Microsoft
any market share or notoriety over the
PlayStation or even the switch it
doesn't seem like Microsoft is willing
to give up though as they're throwing
one last Hail Mary with their $69
billion acquisition of Activision
Blizzard but will this acquisition
actually turn things around for Xbox or
has Microsoft just dug themselves into a
$69 billion deeper
hole to understand why the modern Xbox
is struggling we have to first
understand how the Xbox grew in
popularity in the first place and that
takes us all the way back to March 2nd
1999 the day that the PlayStation 2 was
announced if you didn't know the
PlayStation 2 would go on to be the
bestselling console of all time selling
over 155 million units hearing this a
lot of you are probably inclined to
think that the Xbox was an offensive
move from Microsoft they saw how
successful the PS2 was and they wanted a
piece of the pie but but that's actually
not how things played out it turns out
that the Xbox was actually more of a
defensive move you see the PS2 wasn't
just a gaming console it was actually
more of a multimedia device something
that Sony has only built on over the
years it could play CDs and the DVDs and
Microsoft began to fear that this would
allow Sony to eat into their personal
computer market share so Microsoft
decided to flex on Sony by showcasing
their own multimedia technology Suite
direct X direct X is basic basically the
middleman and windows machines that
interprets code and translates it into
graphics and sound direct X was not only
robust and reliable but it was familiar
to developers because given that it was
from Microsoft it worked seamlessly with
Windows 2000 so Microsoft decided to
just Port Windows 2000 then direct X
into a dedicated gaming console called
the direct Xbox or Xbox for short and
the pitch for developers was that
developing games for the Xbox would be
similar to developing PC games and the
pitch worked alongside the launch of the
original Xbox on November 15 2001 we
would see the launch of a legendary
gaming series Halo and this brings us
into the first factor that made Xbox so
successful iconic exclusive games
naturally a lot of Gamers hate exclusive
games because it forces them to buy
multiple consoles just to play all of
the best games on the market but from a
corporate perspective exclusive games
are critical when it comes to building a
loyal fan base and boosting sales
Microsoft understood this perfectly as
the Xbox was initially defined by a slew
of exclusive games and series like Halo
Forza The Witcher left for dead Call of
Duty 2 Elder Scrolls 3 and Doom 3
justtin name a few but over the years
this list has gotten smaller and smaller
to the point that Xbox series X and S
exclusives can be counted on one hand
it's basically just forsa Horizon 5 Halo
infinite Starfield and Microsoft flight
simulator I suspect that most simulator
fans would prefer to play Microsoft
Flight light simulator on a PC so the
Xbox really only has fora Horizon 5 Halo
infinite and Starfield going for it when
you look at the games that are exclusive
to or optimized for the PS5 on the other
hand you have all of these considering
this it's no wonder why the PlayStation
and the switch have been crushing the
Xbox both of them have a bunch of
exclusive titles that make the console
worth owning unlike the Xbox but how did
Microsoft even end up in this situation
wasn't the Xbox supposed to be the
easiest console to develop for because
of its similarities with Windows well it
turns out that that by itself was not
enough one of the biggest factors
holding back developers from preferring
the Xbox over the PlayStation is its
discrepancy and performance the
PlayStation has historically always been
more powerful than the Xbox but this
extra power also came with a high higher
price tag the Xbox 360 for example
launched at $400 while the PS3 launched
at $500 to $600 adjusting for inflation
the PS3 cost as much as
$880 so the Xbox was able to reach a
demographic that the PlayStation may
have never reached making it worth it to
develop Xbox
games but over the years Sony has
slightly pulled back their prices while
Microsoft has slightly pushed up their
prices such that the PlayStation and
Xbox are pretty much much identically
priced but while the price of the
consoles are the same the same cannot be
said about their performance the PS4 was
objectively more powerful than the Xbox
in fact as much as 40% more powerful
this disparity has only been exacerbated
by the new generation of consoles
because Microsoft has gone out of their
way to launch a lower-end Xbox called
the series s which game developers
aren't exactly a fan of they're
basically having to Nerf their games
into Graphics to accommodate for the
series s in fact some games have even
been delayed because developers have had
a tough time nerfing performance for the
series S without sacrificing performance
for the series X this is rather annoying
even as a secondary release so I think
you can see why developers are hesitant
to bet on an exclusive Flagship on the
Xbox but the whole rivalry between the
PlayStation and the Xbox only tells half
the story because there's very much a
dark core set to play PC gaming remember
remember how one of the biggest
advantages of the Xbox originally was
its similarities to PC it was easy to
Port games from PC to Xbox and vice
versa well this has actually turned into
a massive disadvantage because now there
is no such thing as a true XBox
exclusive basically every XBox exclusive
is also available on PC this wasn't a
big deal back in the 2000s and early
2010s because only these super nerds
with massive budgets gamed on PC but
ever since the launch of AMD ryzen
building PCS has become a lot more
budget friendly and popular this trend
has only been accelerated by the
explosion of Esports which has made PC
gaming cooler than ever what does this
all mean you ask well if you really want
to play Microsoft exclusive games it
often just makes more sense to get a PC
the PC can not only run the games much
better but it can also do a lot more
than just gaming if all of that wasn't
bad enough the Xbox has been facing a
another major obstacle as well which is
the larger interests of Microsoft since
the launch of the original Xbox
Microsoft has grown from a few billion
doll company to a few trillion dollar
company and considering that prosecutors
wanted to break up Microsoft back when
there were just a few hundred billion
doll company Microsoft is now a larger
Target than ever so the last thing they
want to do is show off monopolistic
Tendencies by launching a bunch of
exclusive games just to win over the
gaming Market in fact Satya nadela has
gone on record stating that he wants to
end Xbox exclusives and that the ball is
now in Sony's court but if that's the
case why in the world did Microsoft
complete their biggest acquisition of
all time and spend $69 billion to buy
Activision
Blizzard from a general sense it's
obvious why Microsoft bought activation
blizzard it's obviously to control a
larger portion of the gaming Market and
make more money but if we take a closer
look at the acquisition and see how
Microsoft Executives talk about it we'll
see that the acquisition is less of an
expansion play and more of a pivot play
and we can take it from the horses mouth
itself the CEO of Microsoft gaming Phil
Spencer when asked about the reasoning
behind the activis blizzard acquisition
Phil said quote the biggest gaming
platform on the planet is mobile phones
1 and A2 billion people play on mobile
phones
we really started the discussions
internally at least on activation
blizzard around the capability they had
on mobile and then PC with blizzard
those are the two things that were
really driving our interest in other
words Microsoft bought activation
blizzard to dominate the mobile and PC
space not the console space this might
be a bit confusing given that a lot of
us see activation as the OG console gam
maker but it turns out that they have
evolved quite a bit over the years in
fact 43 % of the revenue comes from
Mobile gaming which is the company's top
performer largely due to mobile hits
like Call of Duty war zone Mobile in
fact console gaming is now their worst
performing division only accounting for
a quarter of their revenue Microsoft
isn't too concerned about this though
because they're looking to Branch out
Beyond consoles because well the Xbox
isn't even doing all that well and
there's a massive gaming Market beyond
that would Microsoft actually put so
much history behind them and completely
pivot their gaming strategy though
well if SAA nadela has one superpower
it's not letting ego Cloud his business
judgment if it's better to run servers
on Linux than Windows he'll do it if
it's better to expand office to iOS
devices and put down the windows phone
he'll do it if it's better to kill
Internet Explorer and develop a new Edge
that runs up Google Chromium well he'll
do it so considering his track record I
don't think you'll hesitate to make a
similar decision with the gaming
industry if the Xbox simply isn't
cutting it and mobile and PC gaming are
working out a lot better he'll shift
Microsoft Focus to mobile and PC gaming
and it seems that this is already
starting to happen the next Xbox is
envisioned to be less of a traditional
gaming console that competes directly
with the PlayStation and be more of a
hybrid cloud gaming platform what that
exactly means is not clear but one thing
is for sure Microsoft is not afraid to
experiment and take risks with the Xbox
that's arguably why they launched two
different consoles the series X and s in
the first place they understood that
their old approach simply wasn't working
so they wanted to try something new
unfortunately it doesn't seem like this
new strategy worked out either and who
knows how the cloud-based console will
play out so the Glory Days of Xbox may
very well be behind us but don't count
out Microsoft just yet while they may
not be the king of console gaming they
may very well become the king of the
gaming industry at large with
historically High interest rates the the
appeal of bills and bonds is higher than
ever yet traditional brokerages haven't
really adapted with the times they still
expect people to use clunky Bond tables
scroll through long overwhelming lists
and even use Virtual keyboards till
recently and that's why we created our
own modern Bond platform Silo at Silo we
prioritize the user experience and the
ease of finding and investing in the
issuers you know and trust so that you
too can easily lock in high yields also
choosing a strong user experience does
not mean sacrificing unsafety every Salo
account is ensured by $500,000 in sipc
insurance and $2.5 million in FDIC
Insurance also all funds deposited on
the platform will be maintained by our
trusted custodian interactive brokers
who has experienced managing $373
billion worth of assets over the past 45
years so if you're looking for a modern
way to invest in bonds please consider
checking out Silo in the description
below unlike Microsoft Sony is killing
it with the PS5 but the problem for Sony
is that that's the only place they're
killing it check out this video to learn
more but until then I'm har and I'll see
you guys on the next
one